let's take a look at the monthly active
users coming in at 316 million if you
strip out some of items that have been
added you're looking at growth of about
300 4 million what's your take well I
think twitter's growth is not fast
enough to satisfy investors that's a
simple answer on the other hand their
bottom line was better than many people
expected and revenue is beat
expectations you know Twitter is an
extraordinary company with extraordinary
cultural currency that is just
struggling to develop a business that
justifies its very hefty valuation but I
think with Jack Dorsey temporarily at
the helm this is a company that's
showing some more life in it than
frankly I and I think other people had
expected so overall I'd say this is a
very good afternoon for Twitter David so
you mentioned that the the user growth
still is not impressive enough to you
know for Wall Street but they did beat
on the financial numbers so are they
doing a better job of monetizing the
user base oh I think they really are
this is a company that nobody really
knew how they'd make any money and this
year they're going to have two billion
in revenue a little more than two
billion in fact they up their estimates
of what the year revenue would be and
that's extremely impressive from a
growth point of view but the problem is
they have a market cap that's you know
somewhere in closing in on 25 billion
and you know they're losing money they
have huge amounts of stock-based
compensation that they have to deal with
every quarter and you know like I said
before you know it's amazing no news
event in politics or entertainment
happens anymore without Twitter being
part of the story somehow there's got to
be a way to monetize that better than
they have I happen to think they are
ultimately a media distribution platform
and if you look at some of their new
products and sort of acquisitions
whether it's vine or periscope or this
thing they're working on called moments
or some other possible name that could
aggregate news event information I think
they're moving towards some very
interesting possible businesses
on the road I still think frankly the
stock is pretty pricey considering the
company's results at the moment so David
we're looking at the stock is up over
six percent almost six percent after
hours is this report enough to shake off
the monkey on this back that it's had
for the last three months I would say
not really i think the key is going to
be who do they announced as the new CEO
if it's somebody that the market likes
their stock could really go up jack
dorsey i think is a good chair taker
right now he's got a lot of respect
inside the company and outside but it's
a caretaker government right you know I
mean it's not really a regime that's
that's that's going to be capable of
espousing a vision for the long term and
this company needs a fundamentally new
vision for the long term until we see
that I don't think the monkeys going to
get off its back